you know what's up everybody this
International master Daniel ranch here
with chess calm back today with another
fast-paced in your face fun description
of a tournament opening we're here today
to discuss the night or Sicilian if
you'd like to see more about the first
few moves that have been played up to
this point you can check out
international master Bruce's video on
the intro to the Sicilian here in our
library Black has two main options on
move to both d6 and Knight to c6 being
those after the move to d6 which is what
we're discussing here and the mainline
moves of the open Sicilian are played we
see the knight of Sicilian reached on
move five the knight of has a flexible
move that not only controls the b5
square preventing white from accessing
it but also prepares to move b5
hopefully launching an attack on the
Queen side and many Sicilians we know
the black is playing on the Queen side
as soon as he's captured this pawn on d4
opening the C file if b5 is achieved
this move tends to support the move b4
which in turn increases blacks pressure
on the center as it removes White's
Knight from the critical post this is
one of the main ideas behind the knight
or from something to keep in mind in
every Sicilian as it's an option to gain
space and attack on the Queen side for
black the main idea behind the knight RF
and that playing a6 on move 5 is the
black maintains flexibility in the
center with his e pawn depending on how
wide chooses to develop a move like
Bishop e3 being one example black can
choose to play either east six which is
a Scheveningen structure a more flexible
move that maintains control over these
critical squares after which black will
typically develop on the Kings side and
after castling look to expand on the
Queen side develop the LightSquared
Bishop and as we said use the threats of
the pawns advancing combined with the
power of the open C file for good play
on the Queen side if black chooses
instead to play the movie 5 Black's idea
is that though he has given a more
control over the central light squares
something white would look to exploit
for the rest of the game he has also
gained a tempo on White's Knight in this
way black can now finish his development
with either one of these bishops coming
out next and when the next few moves we
tend to see that black will have gained
a small amount of time in his
development because of the tempo he
gained when he attacked white knight
and he will then focus his efforts once
again to the open sea file launching the
b-pawn and gaining good attacking
chances on the queenside from whites
perspective white has a few different
moves here Bishop g5 is the main line
Knight orff after which black will
almost always have to play e6 as it
doesn't make sense to play e5 when White
has already put more pressure on the
light scores by pinning the knight on f6
so after East six we tend to see a few
different moves for white but the main
one being f4 and this is the main line
Knight or F where black has maintained
this flexible tension in the center and
white has a small lead in development to
compensate for it again the themes I've
already highlighted a black trying to
play on the Queen side being main
features here any other developing moves
for white will lead to very similar
choices with black having a choice
between these two different structures
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you around on chess calm